et bonjour aujourd'hui on se parle de ça
c'est le samsung galaxy à 53,5 visuel
samsung galaxy à 53 5 g je voulais déjà
présenté il ya quelques semaines déjà je
crois en même temps je vous présentais
le samsung galaxy à 33 5 g qui lui n'est
pas encore arrivé à l'os de samsung mais
qui ne saurait tarder mais lui il est
arrivé lui arriver il est là il est
présent il est là et je m'amuse avec et
j'ai fait des trucs j'ai fait des photos
je me suis baladée je me suis amusé
alors qu'aujourd'hui c'est le jour où je
donne mon retour sur ce smartphone de
samsung et je crois je crois sans me
tromper que ça va être le smartphone en
volume qui sera le plus vendu dans la
toute l'année a priori 2022 par samsung
parce que c'est un peu ce qui se passe
au niveau de la gamme à la gamme ac le
milieu de gamme chez samsung et tout ce
qui va être à 50 à 51 à 52 et là je
pense pour lui à 53,7 des smartphones a
voulu m'essayer ce matin de vachement
bien placé vachement intéressant donc je
vais vous dire si ce smartphone a il
faut venir se positionner au alors s'il
faut carrément venir l'oublier c'est un
sujet super cool parce que j'aime bien
ce smartphone j'aime bien cette gamme
j'aime bien cette marque j'aime bien
l'expérience logiciel qu'on a au travers
du tout sans avoir là donc on va venir
en parler et on va regarder aujourd'hui
si le samsung galaxy à 53,5 jette un
smartphone intéressant et
potentiellement fait pour vous allez on
y va
la première chose à faire retourner un
garnement smartphones ces regards des
smartphones oui et non c'est regarder la
boîte parce que regarder cette boîte
elle est cool mais elle est fine et elle
est fine ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que vous n'avez pas de bloc de charge à
l'intérieur alors vous pouvez venir
recharger jusqu'en 25 watts permettra de
recharger à 50% en quoi en 30 minutes ok
c'est bien c'est rapide mais vous n'avez
pas de bloc de charges alors c'est pas
que nouveaux appuis samsung n'est pas le
seul à le faire sont des questions
environnementales les constructeurs se
disent on veut plus mettre blog de
charge parce qu'on a déjà des
smartphones avant ou qu'on peut venir
acheter un bloc de chasse on regardera
peu plusieurs smartphones donc autant ne
pas venir en mettre un à chaque fois ça
évite la surconsommation et ça c'est
bien ça c'est un dans le bon sens mais
du point de vue consommateur sac défense
dit j'ai pas de bloc de charges ça fait
un peu râler que vous avez le strict
minimum et tout en sachant plus si vous
l'avez pas encore vu regarder et bien
que cette année en 2022 la législation
française je parle pour ceux qui sont en
france si vous êtes ailleurs coucou
aussi avoué bien n'oblige plus à mettre
des écouteurs filaires à une époque on
mettait des écouteurs filaires il n'y a
pas très longtemps pour venir et protégé
de l'exposition aux ondes lorsqu'on est
passé un coup de fil on vous recommande
d'utiliser un petit kit sont enfin avec
fils ou son fils d'alerté villach la bon
aujourd'hui on vous le recommande
toujours mais on vous met pas les
écouteurs donc si vous voulez des
écouteurs aller acheter les acheter à
les acheter les acheter filer les
acheter et également pour votre blog de
charge je vous mets le lien en bas dans
la description également pour ce
smartphone directement sur le site de
samsung ça c'est plutôt intéressant
voilà ça c'est la base de la base je
voulais commencer par là et ensuite je
continuais en vous parlant du smartphone
parce que ce smartphone il est
intéressant alors il ya des choses qui
me plaisent beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
il ya un truc qui me fait râler chez
vous expliquer ce qui me plaît beaucoup
c'est ce smartphone je trouve les juifs
et combien j'ai noté la 189 g je trouve
vraiment léger il a une super prise en
main il est assez long très honnêtement
ce que vous avez un grand écran qui fait
6,5 pouces mais pour autant la prise en
main est bonne le smartphone est cool il
est léger et ça c'est vachement bien il
est léger mais pourtant c'était une
grosse batterie de 5000 milles et
antérieures donc là dessus y'a pas de
soucis donc ça c'est vraiment le premier
point ça me plaît et quand on a un joli
smartphone qu'est-ce qu'il faut venir
faire il faut bien protéger c'est donc
aujourd'hui une vidéo qui a réalisé en
partenariat avec mon partenaire
rhinochill pour venir vous présentais et
bien déjà leurs nouveautés et tous qui
viennent proposer leurs déjà il faut
savoir qu'avec le code gros 22 vous
profitez de -5% dormi surtout citrine
o'shea laisse assez bien alors chez
rhinochill vous avez plein plein de
produits vous avez déjà on va appeler
ses les solides suite et les solitudes
elles sont cools pourquoi parce que déjà
pour des coques de protection 1 l
protégez votre smartphone ce sont des
coques pour l'iphone est ce 3 vous avez
également pour l'iphone 13 promet vous
en avez bien évidemment pour votre
samsung galaxy à 53 également pour le
samsung galaxy à 73 mais aussi pour
plein d'autres smartphones chez samsung
ou ailleurs vous avez plus de 120
modèles de smartphones différents
samsung xiaomi apple one + huawei donc
autant vous dire qu'ici vous avez trouvé
votre bonheur vous pouvez bien
personnaliser vos coque mais vous avez
également des comme dans différents
univers ici ça va être le quinze de
france vous allez avoir mohamed ali
également très sympa star wars ça c'est
chouette mais également des coques
solide suite un peu plus standard si on
va rester dans la sobriété on peut le
faire il ya une nouveauté sherin o'shea
d'or ça c'est uniquement pour votre
iphone vous avez les clés requise n'est
qu'hier que c'est super intéressant ce
sont des coques 100% transparente
garantie anti jaunissement garder mon
prime de base celle là totalement
transparente vous pouvez le mettre sur
votre smartphone vers des aplats ici sur
un iphone 13 promax on a l'impression de
quasiment pas à bangkok mais néanmoins
c'est bien vous le protéger mais elles
sont également personnalisables avec
toutes les licences qu'on va venir
retrouver regardez moi des choses qui
sont vraiment extrêmement sympa
maintenant la captain america on a dû
star wars on a depuis on a un peu plein
de trucs donc ça c'est vachement sympa
vous pouvez en plus venir personnaliser
le contour ici là alors là on vous le
montre en noir mais vous l'avez
également en rose ici je les gardais
dans la boîte vous pouvez également
venir personnaliser les boutons que vous
allez avoir enfin bref on peut vraiment
faire à tout ce qu'on veut il y en a de
toutes les couleurs cheryl logique pour
faire ce qu'ils aiment bien en fait
venir à customiser personnalisés
regardez il y en a de tous les côtés et
en plus sur cinq l'irc eyes vous avez
même des tours de cou garder je vous
montrera à venir ajoutent un tour de cou
donc si vous voulez garder votre
smartphone qui pendouille autour du cou
vous pouvez le faire ça bien le
sécuriser ces pratiques et ça c'est bien
on vient trouver cette clé requises pour
les gan iphone 12 et iphone 13 sauf les
iphone mini et vous avez en plus des
coques pour vos airs paul donc si vous
avez des ipod et s'ils voulaient venir
mettre des coques pour les décorer et
les protégez vous pouvez le faire très
facilement vous avions toutes les
options de personnalisation avec
également la possibilité d'avoir un
marquage premium avec une gravure doré
ou argenté d'un texte vous pouvez
également créer votre coque avec un
photocall a jamais de votre tête très
facilement si vous souhaitez au la tête
de votre chat bref vous en avez pour
tous tout le monde n'est pas un
smartphone donc plein d'univers donc ça
c'est vachement bien souvenez-vous le
code re 22 - 5 % de remise sur
l'ensemble du site de rideau chine je
vous mets le lien bien évidemment en bas
dans la description et merci à rideaux
shield avoir sponsorisé cette vidéo
deuxième point qui m'intéresse ici c'est
je trouve que les lignes sont bien fait
bien dessinés voyez avec ce petit côté
légèrement incurvé qui remontent pour
vous faire dépasser ce blog photo alors
aujourd'hui dépasse pas énormément il ya
des smartphones ça dépasse beaucoup plus
mais bon voilà il faut un peu de place
pour le petit si on veut avoir des
optiques un peu sympa et aujourd'hui au
niveau technologique on a besoin d'avoir
de la place pour l'optique donc ça je
trouve aussi intéressant alors il ya
plusieurs couleurs mais bon je vais pas
vous faire les sens des couleurs à les
voir bien le lien je vous ai mis en bas
directement sur le site de cintheaux
vous verrez toutes les couleurs donc ça
c'est cool prise en main bien harmonieux
on a les boutons sur le côté fermé c'est
un très grand classique 1 c'est un très
joli smartphones ok maintenant il faut
que tu me fait râler et ça c'est tout le
temps chez samsung et ce n'est que chez
samsung c'est à dire qu'on nous dit ok
ok ok on enlève les blocs de charge ok
ok ok on enlève les écouteurs pour des
questions d'écologie mais alors pourquoi
est-ce que ça le soum vous me laissez du
plastique tout autour du smartphone
puisque on se parle d'écologie on va
commencer par retirer le plastique c'est
bien de faire des boîtes en carton mais
regardez je n'ai pas enlevé exprès pour
vous le montrer chez samsung sur les
smartphones vous avez toujours pour
mieux je pense le protéger des petits
bouts de plastoc qu'on vous met tout
autour du smartphone et alors c'est
chouette parce que lorsque vous ouvrez
effectivement l'année vous avez votre
expérience vous aurez votre petit
plastique mais la réalité c'est que sur
votre smartphone de samsung eh bien vous
avez du plastique alors il y en a gardé
et donc là je vous le montre que sur une
petite partie ici mais ça fait tout le
tour du bestiau avec des découpes donc
ça c'est un truc qui est pour moi un non
sens parce que on veut aller dans le
sens effectivement de l'écologie et que
ça a un sens retirez les blocs de
charges ça aussi un sens pour les
constructeurs parce que au delà du
phénomène écologique mais ça c'est pas
uniquement liée à samsung on retient les
blocs de charge on garde les smartphones
quasiment même prix on vend des blocs de
charge à part donc quelque part on
augmente les marges parce qu'on en met
un petit peu moins à l'intérieur et vous
vous retrouvez quand même avec du
plastoc et donc voilà donc moi je veux
bien qu'on me parle d'écologie a aucun
problème et je pense qu'effectivement il
ya une volonté d'écologie là dedans mais
bon il faut aller jusqu'au bout a
commencé par me retirer ces plastiques
autour qui pour moi ne servent
strictement à rien du tout donc ça voilà
vous voyez voilà ça c'est sur un
smartphone un seul et ils en ont des
millions donc bon voilà donc pour moi il
faut une vraie cohérence et ça c'est
vraiment un truc à venir retirer parce
que ça pour moi ça me va pas vrai du
tout du tout un bon signal une fois
qu'on a parlé de ça et que j'ai râlé là
dessus eh bien on va continuer à parler
du smartphone parce que ça n'a rien à
voir avec le smartphone le smartphone je
trouve très bien vous avez un très beau
capteur d'empreintes digitales vous
dérouiller très rapidement menton très
léger vous savez c'est lé petit espace
noir que vous avez sur le banc on
appelle ça le menton il est extrêmement
léger mais on est sur un smartphone qui
coûte un peu moins de 500 euros là rien
de config attention je vous dise que
j'ai pas pris le tarif par coeur la
version 628 on est à 459 euros et la
version 8 256 on est à 519 euros je vous
recommande très clairement une version
628 et qui montrera un peu moins drame
effectivement dans un peu moins de
stockage mais vous pouvez venir
augmenter votre stockage jusqu'à un
terrain grâce à une carte microsd donc
ça sert à rien de prendre dont 156 tout
de suite 128 vous avez déjà de quoi
faire d'autant plus qu'aujourd'hui on
utilise beaucoup de services dans le
cloud donc 128 pas de souci ça m'ira
bien d'envoyer ça c'est tout le côté
config de tarifs et puis surtout je vous
dis 459 euros vous avez un super
smartphone autre truc que je trouve bien
c'est que on se dit qu'on est dans 20
sur un smartphone milieu de gamme mais
ils ont quand même mis à vraiment les
moyens corning gorilla glass 5 pour
venir le protéger à l'avant bon ok c'est
pas le dernier mais ça fonctionne quand
même plutôt bien l'autre truc qui est
cool c'est que vous avez un écran donc
6e 5 pouces et très grand super amoled
vous avez un taux de rafraîchissement de
120 m alors attention on n'a pas un taux
de rafraîchissement variables comme on
aurait sur une gamme s yab ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que vous allez aller
2-1 ou d'hyères tu jusqu'à 120 hertz
alors pour leur faire très très courte
le nombre de hertz et quoi c'est le
nombre d'image que vous avez par seconde
donc plus vous avez des images par
seconde plus votre image sera fluide
parce que vous pouvez mettre plus de
choses en fait dans une seconde dans un
intervalle de temps qui lui ne va pas
bouger vous allez mettre un maximum
d'informations donc plus vous mettez
d'information et plus il y aura de
fluidité donc ça c'est cool maintenant
le truc ça sera au détriment de
l'autonomie de votre smartphone parce
que plus vous allez mettre d'image plus
vous allez en maître et plus vous allez
consommer donc ce qui intéresse en selle
sur des smartphones notamment de la
gamme s chez samsung eh bien vous avez
ce qu'on appelle un taux de
rafraîchissement variables ces deux
smartphones qui de façon intelligente
transparente et autres totalement
invisible pour vous va venir faire cette
bascule intelligemment ici c'est pas le
cas alors c'est normal vous n'avez pas
la techno qu'il le fera parce que vous
êtes sur un smartphone à 459 euros donc
bon pas tout avoir vous avez donc le
choix entre ici regardez vous venez dans
écran vous venez ensuite dont fluidité
des mouvements et vous avez le choix
entre soit de les lever 120 hertz tout
le temps soit 60 hertz tout le temps ce
que je vous recommande de vous mettre de
60 hertz tout le temps pour venir gagner
ici en autonomie et si vous sentez
vraiment le besoin lorsque vous venez
jouer à des jeux et que vous voulez
beaucoup de fluidité alors si vraiment
le sens terre ça vous suffit pas vous
pouvez venir toucher en 120 air mais il
faut savoir qu'ici l'autonomie va quand
même diminué ans et pas drastiquement
mais un petit peu quand même donc ça il
faut le savoir donc s'il vous reste plus
beaucoup de batterie que voulait venir
optimisé mettez-vous en 60 hertz après
cet écran je trouve super bien ça me
sauve maîtrise et écran ça fait partie
samsung group dans sa motion groupe vous
avez samsung electronics qui va venir
fabriquer mouvants de ses smartphones
ils ont également samsung display qui le
fabrique les écrans et les vendent à eux
mêmes mais également à leurs partenaires
et on les retrouve chez beaucoup de
fabricants de smartphones entre autres
donc ça c'est plutôt cool donc on a une
superbe balle très bien calibrée dont
vous serez pas déçu là dedans alors
après en termes d'espérance logiciel
puisqu'on voit ça vous avez un thème
sombre comme on est sûr de la molette
des cons à pixels noirs spx à l'état non
convient également gagner en termes
d'énergie donc si vous n'avez plus
beaucoup de batteries 60 hertz et vous
passez en thèmes sombres vous baisser la
luminosité vous avez quand même repartir
pour un petit moment donc ça c'est
plutôt cool autre truc qui est
intéressant ici c'est que vous allez
avoir des haut parleurs stéréo alors une
fois de plus c'est toujours un peu le
même temps que chez les constructeurs
n'ont pas leur principale ici le
deuxième haut parleurs qui est là c'est
pas une expérience parfaite mais à 459
euros je puis vous assurer qu'ils font
tout à fait que ça marche vraiment
vraiment bien voyez
il ya du soleil ce moment
là c'est un peu moins apprécié un peu
moins grave mais il ya du son
vous fait c'est un peu ça conviendra
donc ici en termes d'expérience
multimédia pour venir regarder des films
des séries pour venir vous divertir pour
profiter d'une bonne expérience sonore
ici vous avez ce qu'il faut ce que je
vous conseille quand même c'est de venir
prendre des petits bugs apple et galaxy
buzz je vous ai fait une vidéo sur les
galaxies bled paumé lié à quelque part
par ici ou dans la description pour
aller jeter un oeil dessus pour tout
savoir sur ces écouteurs de samsung ça
peut être intéressant c'est à dire
optimiser l'expérience vous avez
d'ubuntu 5 présente pas de souci pour me
rappellerai beuys très facilement donc
ça c'est cool donc pour tout ce qui va
être multimédia pour tout ce qui va être
divertissement pas de souci elle aura
pris pour le gaming c'est pareil ça
marche très très bien alors je vous
demande sera en jeu qui est extrêmement
classique c'est un asphalte nagy
beaucoup dessus donc je vous demande
directement dessus ça marche bien c'est
fluide ça fonctionne que vous soyez en
soi surtout ans sans rien pour nettement
sa confiance est très très bien bonne
expérience au global ici donc rien
d'étonnant donc pour du gaming vais
faire tourner également beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de jeux dessus donc ça
c'est plutôt à la très très très bonne
nouvelle donc si vous voulez aussi un
smartphone qui vous servira pour venir
jouer avec vous pouvez partir assure ce
galaxy à 53 5 g sans problème vous
retrouvez ci un exil aux 1280 processeur
5 j'ai signé ici sam sous un processeur
maison qui fonctionne plutôt pas mal
donc là dessus il ya de quoi faire au
terme de performance mais évidemment
entendez vous seriez pas faire tourner
les jeux les plus gourmands dre plus
haute confie clairement c'est pas le cas
mais 459 euros en fait plus on y revient
donc je vous dis ça parce que c'est très
équilibré qui est intéressant
l'expérience gaming et là l'expérience
multimédia et la finition est belle tout
l'expérience logiciel avec waneux a ici
aussi super cool c'est très clair très
lisible vous avez toutes vos icônes on
se retrouve c'est vachement bien je vous
ai fait une vidéo pour vous parler de
wendake cas je vous invite à venir voir
parce que vraiment c'est une des
meilleures expériences pour retrouver
vous sur smartphone android ça marche
très très bien alors je vous en ai parlé
lors de la vidéo de présentation ici
vous avez quatre caméras l'arrêt grand
temps ultra grand-angle mode portrait
macro que'il caméra de celle ci ça c'est
très classique alors c'est toujours dans
l'idée du marketing de dire regardez
j'en ai plein j'en ai plein j'ai plein
de caméras dans vos smartphones y en a
tous les côtés en réalité grand teint
ultra grand temps que ce qui est
intéressant ici pas téléobjectif vous
avez un zoom numérique fois disque on
peut venir utiliser avec ce smartphone
pourquoi pas vous allez voir qu'il faut
dix rencontres peut y aller du tout avec
l italie pas mais je vais vous montrer
les résultats dans quelques instants que
vous allez voir mais sinon c'est pas mal
ça s'équilibre et allez on y va vous
allez voir en photo ce smartphone il a
de belles qualités il ya aussi des
choses qui vont pas mais une fois de
plus 459 euros on est dans le milieu de
gamme en cascade mais voilà l'idée c'est
d'avoir un truc qui est cohérent qui va
être plutôt complet qui ne permet pas de
faire de belles photos et beau souvenir
c'est ce qu'on vient chercher ici on va
pas demander de l'exigence c'est pas
parce qu'il écrit samsung qu'on s'attend
à voir le truc voilà on n'est pas dans
la gamme est-ce donc il faut raison
garder je vous montre plusieurs photos
là on est sans capteur principal je me
cherche un peu plus compliqué pour lui
au niveau des hautes lumières pour voir
comment ils en sortent et il s'en sort
pas mal je trouve qu'avec ses hautes
lumières on manque un peu de contraste
voyez au niveau de la face de mon
bâtiment qui est l'opéra bastille il va
avoir un petit peu de mal ici pascal
soleil il me sort quand même des choses
plutôt pas mal au niveau des nuages
lavoyer mais c'est une image qui est un
peu plate qui va me manquer un petit peu
de contraste mais il s'en sort et ça
c'est plutôt bien on continue sur
l'ultra grand temps le leur à la gestion
de la lumière c'est juste chaotique
l'arbre absolument plus rien tout est
cramé mais malgré tout dans ce lot de
kram âge au niveau du ciel on voit notre
façade alors il ya du bruit c'est pas
beau c'est hyper poussif ça marche pas
donc les contre-jours sur l' ultra
grand-angle on sort axe pas fait pour
lui qui va pas y arriver je suis amusé
ou met un petit peu alors au niveau du
zoom pour tout vous dire j'ai un x 2
numérique en x 4 numérique et jusqu'à 1
x 10 numérique c'est tout du numérique
intention ici donc bon c'est pas un truc
de dingue dingue au la cheville au x 2 x
4 x 10 voyez la qualité elle est pas là
donc faut deux s'ils ont envie de se
marrer vite fait on peut mais au-delà de
ça on ira pas dès lors qu'on a le soleil
derrière nous a tout de suite ça va
quand même beaucoup mieux au niveau des
contrastes au niveau de beaucoup de
choses toujours ici et bastille regarder
le ciel je trouve magnifique comme ça il
s'en sort vraiment vraiment bien les
façades sont belles elles sont
contrastées légèrement sursaturé murs de
chez samsung et ça marche parce que ça
va rendre les choses un petit peu plus
belle et ça fonctionnera l'ultra
grand-angle et un poil plus ternes mais
ma et où il fait le taf comme ça donc ça
ira pas trop mal foi de hockey fois
quatre noms fois de 10 noms voilà et
ensuite on peut venir s'amuser à essayer
différents trucs regarder le soleil est
situé sur la gauche de la photo ici on a
un ciel qui est beau qui ressent bien on
a bien des bâtiments limogeage qui
contraste est un poil sursaturé mais ça
fonctionne et je trouve ça sympa c'est
assez joli sur l'ultra grand temps que
ça fonctionnera également comme ça et on
est vite devenir trop zoomer parce que
non voilà voilà donc voyez on peut faire
des choses sympas il s'en sort il fait
du bon taf grand angle ultra grand-angle
à m'accrocher beaucoup moins fan
intentions capteur de 5 mégapixels ici
les résultats et pas dingue on peut
essayer mais bon voilà c'est vraiment
histoire de mettre un capteur bus mais
une fois de plus sont très nombreux à
faire ça mais dès lors vous avez des
photos un peu plus maîtrisée on va pas
les sur des contre jours ils nous sont
des choses qui sont très sympas on voit
qu'un travail algorithmique derrière
pour venir connaître les différentes
scènes et ça marche franchement ça
fonctionne donc pas grand-chose à venir
dire ici de plus je trouve que dans
l'ensemble au niveau de la photo si ce
n'est sur l' ultra grand-angle et hautes
lumières où il est quand même vachement
mal sinon ils s'en sortent dans
l'ensemble plutôt pas mal donc on va
bien privilégier grand-angle
ultra-grand-angle avec une bonne expo la
caméra telle fille je ne suis pas hyper
convaincu il faut un peu de lumière bon
c'est de la faute aux grades et le
traitement de la peau je trouve pas
extrêmement beau jeu montré un peu plus
loin vous allez voir on continue la c1
fin de marché la voyez appelé à regarder
à contre jour je trouve que c'est pas
ouf ça c'est pas contrastées c'est la
lgo qui cherche à compenser on a du coup
du bruit la voyait au niveau de ma part
car ils ne savent pas beau deux faces
tout de suite forcément ça marche mieux
on vient contraster davantage bon voilà
il n'est pas tout terrain en fait si
vous voulez bon là j'ai fait ces
différents trucs dans paris presque
désert la nuit c'est assez marrant qui
s'en sortent pas trop trop mal sur le
capteur principe mais l' ultra
grand-angle on oublie totalement mais
c'est pas de sa faute tous les
smartphones plupart du temps du travail
en tant que ce crash là dessus donc lui
également fois deux voiliers il a
toujours ce petit problème au niveau de
la gestion des hautes lumières et la
nuit c'est la même chose donc attention
ici et du coup on va retrouver du bruit
lavoyer haut niveau sur les vélos donc
c'est pas complètement d'un il faut
vraiment bien venir soit vers sa scène
ultra d'antan je vous ai montré sûr de
ce marais de monts voix c'est tout et on
vient pas où mais non plus on peut faire
des choses voyez avec une lumière un peu
maîtrisée on fait attention aux sources
de lumière qui sont un peu fort et on
arrivera à bricoler un petit peu la nuit
à sortir des trucs les voyons ça reste
quand même très bruitée là au niveau des
véhicules voilà c'est pas le photophone
pour aller a ajouté la nuit on peut
faire quelques souvenirs là voyage il ya
donc une source de l'ue mais reçu
c'était assez brute et c'était pas
dingue voilà c'est vraiment le truc à
retenir ici on peut quand même bien
s'amuse un petit peu alors j'ai tenté du
mode portrait bros voilà support moral
un pas plus pas moins
moi ce que j'aime bien avec ce samsung
galaxy à 53,5 ges et je pense que c'est
un smartphone polyvalent un peu
passe-partout à
459 euros il vous permettra d'avoir une
bonne expérience en termes de
divertissement une bonne expérience de
gamer il fera des photos qui seront
corrects il est actuel alors on n'a pas
de wifi sur notre du wifi 5 mais on a
une certification ip67 qui vous le
certifie étanche contre la pluie et les
poussières donc pas de souci s'il se met
à pleuvoir et que vous prenez un peu
d'eau dessus ou même lorsque vous prenez
à perote des amis a absolument aucun
problème si vous souhaitez l'utiliser
pour du paiement dématérialisé avec
notamment samsung paye ou google paye
bien vous avez du lfc vous pouvez le
faire vous avez une double sim donc si
vous avez deux cartes sim et bien vous
pouvez ici venir les utiliser et on a un
indice de réparabilité de 8,2 sur 10
plutôt correct alors il ya notre mode
dont je vous ai pas parlé au niveau de
la photo que je trouve assez rigolo
c'est ce qu'ils appelleront le mode
amusant alors le mode amusé en fait
c'est quoi ce sont les filtres de
snapshot en fait voyez c'est écrit six
fils d'hosni chaque amendement lorsque
je viens changer de mode je trouve qu'il
est un poil ans c'est un petit peu la
limite du processeur ici le mode amusant
vous l'avez sur la caméra de celle
fissures notre caméra en fait c'est
jamais rien d'autre que du que du snap
j'attends donc vous allez avoir tous vos
petits fils train peut en effet snapshot
histoire de venir vous marrer donc voilà
donc
vous en avez plein au catalogue si voilà
donc bon c'est un truc qui est un peu
marrant en plus vous pouvez élargir
votre caméra de celle-ci ici si vous le
souhaitez très légèrement vous l'avez à
l'avant vous l'avez également à
l'arrière pareil la regarder sur notre
caméra de celle ci un peu standards sont
venir mettre des amis dans le plan et
ben on peut le faire ça mais on nous
annonçait que le mode nuit en photo
serait un peu plus rapide que ce qu'on
avait avant j'ai pas trouvé un très
honnêtement je prends mon smartphone je
shoote je trouve qu'il est un petit peu
lent ça c'est le processeur donc ne fait
pas des merveilles mais pour autant ça
fonctionne mais bon voilà je le trouve
plutôt bien je trouve cohérent c'est un
beau smartphone qui est actuel donc si
vous avez un du lieu aux alentours de
459 euros jusqu'à 519 euros mais 459
suffira largement c'est pas la peine de
venir a ajouté pour gagner un petit peu
d'arabe double le stockage en ce moment
ça servirait à rien la version 628
fonctionnera ici c'est un bon smartphone
qui ne sera pas tout faire mais qui
saura faire un peu tout et c'est l'idée
ça ça me plaît j'espère que ça vous aura
intéressé s'il vous intéresse bien
évidemment que j'ai mis le lien en bas
d'un description pour venir l'acheter
directement sur le site de samsung dont
on se retrouve très vite pour continuer
à parler tech pour continuer à parler à
2 samsung bien évidemment mais également
de plein d'autres choses donc ça c'est
cool je vous embrasse prenez soin de
vous et à très vite qu'un